it was finally here the day I had waited
prepared for the day I would train the
Toronto Maple Leafs today I would skate
alongside defender can cleave right wing
Tom Fitzgerald goalie Trevor Kidd and
its high dome intimidating brothers in
the history of the NHL I wanted
everything let me talk to you a little
bit about hockey hockey was never my
sport I'll be honest I like to nerf
sports mostly things that you can do in
an office space
sitting never really got into hockey but
I think I can learn it pretty quickly
I'm pretty sure that within the hour
I'll be the best hockey player here talk
about fighting alright let's just say
you have a problem with me I got a
problem with you
how would you come at me just show me
what you do okay show me a slow motion
what you do when you have a motion now
yeah yeah you got the Jersey yeah keep
you on the air right right
right like that and then bring it right
across my style is more of a slapping
thing I slap and I keep my elbows in and
I slap you've made a big mistake and I'd
do this does anybody do this anymore
I just want to show you some of the
equipment I've brought I'm not an expert
skater so I had this made I want you
guys to tell me what you think it's a
special skate that I use exclusively for
balance I use this and then to stop I
have a rock tied to a rope throw that
behind me no slows me down I'm just
curious what you guys think of this
but this go over well I've got to
protect the head I'm a thinking man a
cerebral man you see those skates and
this helmet coming at you tell me this
is good nightmare for you is me coming
right at you I'd be laughing my ass off
that's for sure yeah you'd be laughing
and that would distract you and I'd whip
that puck in probably 11 miles an hour
but it's done get it in can you be busy
laughs
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
wait through my stick in the middle
between your feet bring your stick back
about here for a slapper what about here
yeah look where you gonna shoot you got
it my trick it's not next to shoot
though cuz he's expecting that I shoot
away from the goal before he's not
defending hope to hit someone else
pretty smart good that go oh that was
like a magic trick you're gonna take it
out from behind your ear
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you're not thinking you're nowhere guys
as we all know scoring is difficult this
is the approved NHL four by six hockey
net I give you the conan net right here
Ellucian eyes the game bigger scores
more attendance in this version of the
game the goalie on odd-numbered nights
would be allowed to have a piece of
furniture with him to help recliner a
small sectional not a large sectional
it's not a circus
[Music]
that was way too much turning you'll
never use that in a game the problem
with hockey too much turning fans lose
interest get in here
alright guys I'm not liking what I'm
seeing you're dogging it what's problem
you don't seem to care you've lost
interest in the game you're tired tired
from babies babies take naps do you call
that a slap shot
my grandmother throws harder she's been
dead for 20 years what
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I had learned all I could think he's
brave may police have won their respect
and mastered their game I guess
sometimes when a man takes on his heroes
he becomes the greatest hero
[Applause]
you